Worms.
They’re weird, primitive creatures that
seem to just squirm around senselessly.
BUT this simplistic behavior is exactly what
we are looking for in our endeavours to digitize
a living brain.
Now look at this.
This..this looks like a robot being controlled
by an ewok.
But actually, this robot isn’t being controlled
AT ALL.
What you are looking at is a copy of the brain
of a Caenorhabditis elegans, or C. elegans.
This is the digital brain of a worm ON a computer
chip IN a lego robot.
This little guy is a simulated brain navigating
on its own.
Well, navigating the best way a wormbot can.
The scientists put sensors on their robots
“noses” and “tails”so if they meet
a wall, they know to turn around.
Just like the C.elegans.
But, as simple as this robot seems to be,
getting to this point took a long time.
Researchers spent decades looking at each
and every cell in the C.Elegans,and at how
each cell works with the cells around it.
Then other researchers built a program that
could mimic that interaction.Each one of these
boxes represents a neuron interacting with
the environment.
They could do this, because scientists have
a complete map of every single cell in the
C.Elegans and their functions.
It’s the worm’s CONNECTOME, and it holds
around 1000 cells and all 302 neurons of this
little worm.
So, once you’ve digitized how every cell
and neuron interact, you have the digital
version of the C. Elegans brain!
Sort of.
By simulating a brain at a cellular level,
the researchers can watch the larger aspects,
like movement, emerge...naturally.
Or, put another way, they turned it on and
let the wormbot be a worm... bot.
To do this they took the connectome, some
algorithms, and a precise anatomical map and
combined them.
Then they threw it in a simulator -- which
is super complicated, and I don’t really
understand how it all works -- but the important
thing is what happened once they flipped it
on.
The robot behaved like a living C.Elegans!
Well, almost.
The researchers are starting small.
They want to get the neuron’s interacting
with the “muscles” of the robot.
It still doesn’t have independent instinct,
it’s not going to start looking for food
or anything yet.
Those behaviours are definitely on the agenda
for our researchers, but they just want to
get the digital organism moving first.
Now, I know what you’re thinking, is this
a huge step towards some crazy scientists
digitizing and uploading human brains into
robuts!
AHH!!
But, no.
Not really.
No.
These scientists are mapping this worm’s
brain and creating an accurate digital simulation
because WE still don’t know a lot about
how OUR brain works.
This project’s success could completely
change the way we map and understand our own
brain.
Plus, with this application we could possibly
get rid of squishy living organisms in labs
and could rely on computer simulations instead.
There’s nothing to fear…
C.elegans are only 1mm long.It will take a
while before we start digitizing your brains
guys.
For more science in your day, subscribe to
Seeker and are you wondering how our brains
power our thoughts in the first place?
We explain it right here.
Did you know that the C.elegans is the first
animal and currently, ONLY animal with an
entirely mapped connectome?
Pretty cool.
Thanks for watching.